blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman so joe biden is taking a very
different approach to foreign policy
than the former president donald trump
took and we sort of have like one of our
first
big foreign policy conflicts to talk
about there's been a little bit of joe
biden
talking about and around
china policy and tariffs and the like
but now it's putin and now it's russia
and things are very quickly getting
interesting and unfortunately anytime i
touch this issue i have to give some
disclaimers which i'm going to give in a
moment but the question is what's going
on well what's going on is that during a
video call with russian president
vladimir putin yesterday joe biden
issued a warning and the warning said in
very simple terms is do not invade
ukraine or we are going to hit you with
very strong
economic sanctions economic sanctions
and this is one of the first really
major foreign policy events of its kind
with joe biden donald trump made a
really big show
out of
bragging
about how he would deal with
adversarial foreign leaders with putin
it was mostly kid gloves
with kim jong-un it was
falling for the obvious
meaningless platitudes and promises that
we've gotten from every north korean
leader recently and thinking he
accomplished something and you know we
can look at the full list of those uh
relationships well for joe biden it
seems as though it's going to go a
little bit differently now the context
here if you've not been following it is
that u.s intelligence has determined
that russia has massed
what they believe to be 70 000 troops
near the border with ukraine
and appears to be making preparations
for an invasion maybe as soon as early
in 2022 now appears to be making
preparations
is not just technically accurate
it actually may be the entire point
which is to gauge what the reaction is
going to be of other major powers but
we're going to get to that ukrainian
officials are saying
russia's sending tanks
they're sending snipers they're trying
to provoke return fire to then justify a
full invasion that's the position of
ukrainian authorities now i need to make
my disclaimers
i know that for 90 of my audience i
don't have to say this i have to say it
for 10 of my audience but if i don't my
inbox becomes a hellscape i am telling
you what joe biden
is saying to vladimir putin
i am not suggesting war with russia
i am not cheerleading war with russia i
don't want war with russia do not email
me saying david why are you such a
neocon
imperialist that you want war with
russia trump wanted to get along why why
why david i'm not saying that please
don't email me that now in the call the
belief is that biden said if you invade
ukraine we're going to hurt your economy
uh putin was expected to ask for a
guarantee from joe biden that the nato
military alliance will never involve
ukraine ukraine wants membership in that
shared defense alliance putin doesn't
want that now in advance of the call
white house press secretary jensaki put
out a statement where she said quote
we've consulted significantly with our
allies and believe we have a path
forward that would impose significant
and severe harm on the russian economy
you can call that a threat
you can call that a fact you can call
that preparation you can call it
whatever you want to call it that was
gensake on monday so listen this is not
going to go the way it went under trump
this is going to be different
biden is not going to fly to finland
meet with putin do a press conference
where he says i don't know i asked putin
if they hacked us and putin denied it
very strongly okay
i don't know putin said his troops
aren't really massing at the border
they're just passing by on a sightseeing
tour
okay that one i made up the first one
happened under trump that last one i
made up that's not going to be the way
it is under joe biden uh this doesn't
mean we want war with russia this
doesn't mean we want biden starting to
drone russia boots on the ground or any
of the stuff it's also important to
understand
that putin has done this before
and it's not a guarantee
that putin necessarily plans to invade
or wants to invade invade
he
is constantly gauging reactions putin is
not stupid putin is actually a brilliant
guy in his own way and he's gauging
reaction he's sowing chaos he's creating
confusion and massing the troops at the
border may not be a plan to invade i
think the key part here is
there are some people on the pro-trump
right
who are saying
by uh trump sorry putin would never
invade obviously that's not true history
tells us that's not true
what could be true
is that putin does not intend to invade
this particular time and is trying to
see what kind of reaction he can get
last thought on this
one it'll be interesting to see how
putin reacts to biden's warning in other
words if this is a trial balloon
what if anything will joe biden's
warning do to dissuade putin or not
that's number one
and then number two
i got a few emails from people in the
audience thinking along the same lines
which is is it possible that russia and
china are coordinating on ukraine and
taiwan respectively
to do
actions at the same time not not working
together but the timing coordinated
in order to really see
if and what the us and nato are going to
do it's a very interesting speculation
i don't think at this point we have
evidence that that's actually what's
going on
but like everything else we're going to
watch it and it will be very interesting
to see what i mean quite frankly this is
the first kind of adversarial foreign
policy test for joe biden major one
anyway of his presidency so we will
watch it always curious to know your
thoughts
so yesterday we talked about dr anthony
fauci's recent statement that again we
always want to be clear not to overplay
our hand dr fauci on monday said which i
told you about yesterday
anecdotal early data
points in a general way
towards omicron the new covet variant
probably
causing
on average
less severe disease that's like a lot of
hedging and caveats but that's sort of
where our knowledge is at this point in
time
we have another slightly stronger
statement from dr fauci which i'm going
to get to in a moment but first i want
to address something many of you have
been emailing me about saying david sir
why is it if omicron is less severe
that cases are spiking now
cases and severity are two different
things
but the first question we have to answer
to even do this is answer the question
are cases spiking and if so
are they omicron spikes or not
let's start with the numbers
our case is spiking yes very very much
so in insane numbers in the united
states cases are now up to about 117 000
per day
they were down to 72 000 per day in
their their recent bottom now up to 117
000 per day that's a huge increase
nearly a two-thirds increase 63
higher cases per day in the us
the same thing is happening globally
where cases spiked from a low
of about four hundred thousand a day
still a crazy number
up to six hundred and eleven thousand
cases per day that's an increase of
fifty two percent globally so our case
is spiking without a doubt
way way way up
it's not only cases that are spiking
hospitalizations are also way up in the
united states we now are about 6 000 new
hospitalizations for covet per day we
had been down to about 2500 at one point
over the summer
but the key question is
is this a sign of omicron spreading
wildly and putting people in the
hospital and so far the answer is no it
appears that while
a higher percentage of new cases are
omicron higher and higher over time
the current spike in cases is being
driven by the delta variant and the rise
in hospitalizations
definitely being driven by the delta
variant per
some analyses now on omicron we also
heard from dr fauci again and dr fauci
is now speaking with slightly more
certainty
slightly more
definitiveness who says that it's going
to take weeks to know for sure
but early indications suggest
that the severity of omicron cases is no
worse than previous strains
and possibly
milder which would be very welcome
the not so good
it spreads like wildfire
reinfections appear to be higher
but on severity dr fauci is saying it
almost certainly is not more severe than
delta now still if it's as severe and
more contagious it's not a big victory
uh and it's going to take more time to
determine the specifics we're also
getting more and more anecdotes about
just how easily omicron spreads last
week i spoke with nicolas christakis and
he talked about this anecdote
which he said is it's an important
anecdote about two travelers
quarantining in hong kong
one who opened the door for room service
and then another across the hall who
later opened the door caught the virus
now as nicolas christakis said
could it
that might not have been how he caught
it there could be more to that but as an
anecdote pretty pretty horrifying stuff
other anecdotes
69 of 150 participants at a danish
christmas party have now tested positive
for omicron about half about half of the
attendees
nearly 70 intensive care medics
at a spanish hospital
now have covered after a christmas party
not yet totally clear if that's omicron
so we want omicron to be milder
it's clearly very contagious
and we're going to have to keep waiting
to get definitive information but the
hope would be
equally or slightly more contagious but
dramatically less severe particularly if
there's going to be immune evasion
that would be sort of the ideal
outcome and remember
over time
evolutionary pressure for these viruses
is more transmissible
less severe
to the point where
is could it be in a year
could it be two years
could it be five years i don't know five
years is more depressing but it could be
a very contagious cold
indistinguishable from the average
head cold
in terms of severity that is the
trajectory to sort of hope for at this
point in time and how long it'll take to
become a reality
is a question that we don't yet have an
answer to let me know your thoughts and
maybe maybe just as importantly find me
on twitter at dpakman and let me know
are you now doing something differently
based on omicron based on omicron
relative to what you were doing before
are you doing anything differently now
find me on twitter at dpakman let me
know and remember that next tuesday this
coming tuesday december 14th we'll be
doing our next david pakman show viewer
town hall we will be streaming it live
on the pacman live youtube channel and
you will be able to participate
via the david pakman show discord
remember that members will get priority
access during the town hall sign up at
jointpakman.com
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
welcome back to the show everybody we uh
we're continuing to try to close out
2021 as strongly as possible i mentioned
earlier this week
the last six months have been a little
tougher for the show quite frankly and
although the audience has kept growing
the economic situation has led to a lot
of people cancelling memberships and
things are looking a little bit less
good so i want to reinvite you
to sign up at joinpackman.com we've made
an offer which several dozen folks have
availed themselves of which is if you
get a membership for the year at full
price on our website i'll send you a
free t-shirt you're of your choice you
can choose i mean listen of course you
can pick the size it would be crazy if i
said you've got to have a 2xl that would
be nuts what kind of a host would i be
you can pick the design you can pick the
color so free t-shirt sent to you
anywhere in the world
with a full price yearly membership at
joinpakman.com just sign up and email
info davidpakman.com and we'll get that
out to you asap
and you can also get memberships for
just a couple bucks a month a month if
you use the code
uh better21 the codebetter21 will give
you a big discount off of the membership
of your choice would love
for you to sign up
there's a very good article in the
atlantic called trump's next coup has
already begun and the article is by
barton gellman
and barton's main argument
is that january 6th was essentially
practice it was a dry run
of new techniques and tactics to subvert
an election
and gelman says that now donald trump's
gop whether trump himself is part of it
or not and that's a really important
thing whether or not trump is part of
trump's gop
they are now much better positioned to
subvert the next election and gelman
points out among a number of important
things
that the next coup is likely to look a
lot less like a coup and this is what's
so dangerous and pernicious about it and
it's really like if you if you have one
take away from this story it's
the coup is going to look a lot less
like a coup
if you can make the coup attempt not
look like one it is way more likely to
succeed and it's way more likely to
raise eyebrows and ruffle feathers
after the 2020 election
and even in the lead up where trump was
already talking about i might not accept
the results etc
um trump's actions looked like a coup
attempt the january sixth insurrection
blatantly looked like a coup attempt
trump trying to strong-arm mike pence
obvious coup attempt but the next one
might not so obviously look like a coup
they tried it in 2020 in a pretty damn
brazen way but after seeing what worked
and what didn't work
now
they're in a position to be able to set
up the next attempt
slightly more
surreptitiously they're setting up
systems to have partisan control
over which ballots are counted and which
ballots are thrown out
they're creating partisan mechanisms to
certify or reject election results
on the basis of party lines and as
gelman writes in the atlantic and re
read the article we're linking to it
it's very good they are driving out or
stripping power from election officials
who refuse to go along with the coup
attempt from last november
and december and january i mean the
attempt really lasted quite a long time
and remember that even their legal
arguments failed in 2020 they had those
dozens of court challenges they were all
thrown out
but they are
fine
uh
fine-tuning or calibrating i guess we
could say
the legal aspects as well to have a
better shot if next time they use
slightly less crazy legal arguments and
they have
slightly more right-leaning judges that
get to decide
maybe they actually get something done
so that's the behind the scenes now the
plain view piece is an important part
because it's not just what you do behind
the scenes it's what's the public
attitude to what you're doing
they are continuing to hammer publicly
on people with the results can't be
trusted anybody might have won the
results aren't secure
the claims of fraud are generally true
the idea there is you fine-tune the
mechanisms behind the scenes you create
a public that believes you can't trust
the results you're much more likely to
set yourself up for some level of
success both by having the tactics in
place
and by having as much of the population
as possible in a state of mind where
they say
i don't really know who won let them do
it let them do this because it's not
even really clear who won because
there's so much fraud you create a
public
more willing to accept a reversal
on the basis of supposed fraud and
meanwhile you work the systems that will
actually allow you to do it hoping
enough people look the other way and
this is why i continue to insist
the 2020 big lie
and the insurrection
it's a horror not just for what it was
on the merits but it's a horror for what
it might open the door to in the future
because
i don't want to say it almost worked but
it came closer to having an impact than
we would like to see and i hate to say
this because it's really scary
i don't know that joe biden and the
current slate of democrats are really
set up to fight it i'm not saying
they're incapable but they don't seem to
either
be paying enough attention
or be willing enough to really do what
it takes there's not enough public
awareness here about the fact that this
is not it's not like oh we tried a coup
in 2020 we didn't get it that's it now
we're gonna try to win on policy right i
mean that's not what they're doing there
are not enough safeguards being put in
place to counter what republicans have
done in the last year and quite frankly
i mean you could even go back and say
what happened in 2000 in bush v gore
with the supreme court catherine harris
florida
that should have been maybe it was i
mean it
should have been a signal
that
they are going to do it again
and they're going to try harder and
harder
and they are going to try to win not by
getting more votes by earning votes
they're going to try to do it with voter
suppression
gerrymandering and now this new level
which is just saying we won and trying
to sue their way into office the left
may partially be weaker
but also the left is not even playing
the same game the the right have given
up on governance and policy completely
they've given up on convincing voters
what we offer is better and we can prove
it
they certainly will say what we offer is
better because they're offering
communism which is a lie
but they are about cultural issues
they're about owning the libs they're
about winning by gerrymandering and
cheating everything they do is done with
the next election in mind how can we
take the next election this applies to
voters as well
during bush and obama
republicans would say using the military
is good your alpha if you want to send
the military here and there and bush was
good because he did it and obama's bad
because he's not doing it under trump it
then became well now war is bad war is
bad hillary will get us into wars vote
trump because war is now bad under biden
getting out of afghanistan goes back to
being bad trump would have done it
better
he would have done it later or earlier
differently better this is the asymmetry
problem that i've pointed out that they
are operating in a completely different
way and it's going to be even more
noticeable going forward
let's talk a little bit about something
we've discussed quite a bit over the
last three to four months
i've been talking to you
about the growing rift within the
republican party this sort of civil war
as we're calling it which has mostly
been trump republicans versus slightly
less bonkers republicans people like liz
cheney
adam kinzinger
mitt romney and some others and i've
also said before
the republican civil war is good for the
left the left should encourage it let's
help along the republican civil war
let's weaponize the republican civil war
against them to any extent that we can
we now have a new participant in this
civil war who seems to be trying to play
both sides we we've not seen this before
and i'm talking about republican
congressman dan crenshaw dan crenshaw
who has put out very confused takes
about socialism and different things he
seems smart enough to realize
that he needs to figure out a way to
play both sides on this republican civil
war
he is actually hugely pro-trump on
policy which is hilarious because it's
like what policy but okay during the
trump presidency crenshaw defended
trump's coveted policy
totally abortive policy crenshaw
defended it trump said he liked trump's
economic policy uh crenshaw said he
liked trump's economic policy
but he's not big on the theatrics he's
not big on the cartoonish nuttery of the
right or at least not as big
well crenshaw spoke at the texas liberty
alliance and he did something that's
very interesting he trashed the
cartoonish pro-trump people
by saying they're grifters
they didn't actually vote
with trump as much as i did i being
crenshaw
and it's sort of like treading water so
check out this clip and now understand
that when crenshaw talks about the
freedom caucus he's talking about
marjorie taylor green mo brooks paul
gozar louis gohmert jim jordan those
types of kooky for coco puffs
republicans take a look supporting these
two
actually other veterans and morgan's
race
there's other front runners but why
support these two well because i've been
in congress for almost three years now
there's two types of members of congress
there's performance artists and there's
legislators
now the performance artists are the ones
that get all the attention
but the ones you think are more
conservative because they know how to
say slogans real well
they know how to recite the lines that
they know that our voters want to hear
let me tell you guys something in the
first two years of trump's presidency
when republicans were in control
when every single time we were voting on
donald trump's agenda
who do you think was at the top of that
list voting with trump and who do you
think was at the bottom
a lot of names you would recognize were
at the bottom of that list
a lot of things you recognize are at the
top of that list
number two it's probably going to make
you cringe a little bit
it's adam kensinger
voted with trump almost 99
he was number two
but it was at the bottom
everybody in the freedom caucus
all of them
what you hear so often
is not true
it's not true we have grifters in our
midst not here not like in this room
that's not what i mean
i mean in the conservative movement
lie after a lie after lie because they
know something psychologically about the
conservative part
we're worried about what people are
going to do to us what they're going to
infringe upon us
so that is super interesting
first of all
crenshaw straight up says
these people
green and the her ilk these are
performance artists and grifters okay
fair so crenshaw must be an anti-trump
republican right wrong
he is criticizing them as grifters
because they perform and they do the
theatrics but at the end of the day
they are not actually pro-trump enough
in terms of how they vote
he says they should be more truly
pro-trump by actually supporting more of
trump's policies back while donald trump
was president and then he says hey you
know who does
adam kinzinger kinzinger is good so then
you might say if you've been following
the way the battle lines have been drawn
you might say wow
that's a big attack on the trump people
because among republicans
there's been no bigger critic of trump
than adam kinzinger right well no not
really because crenshaw is saying
kinzinger is good because he supports
trump more often than these freedom
caucus people based on voting so there's
three takeaways here and they're all
important number one
crenshaw is smart enough to recognize
the rift
and he's sort of trying to play both
sides for now because it's unclear what
the future of the republican party is in
2022 and 2024.
is it a trumpian republican party in the
coming election year and in 2024 or is
it not so that's one thing that that
he's doing number two
the civil war is real
and it should be encouraged because this
is exactly the type of confusion that
can create factions where republicans
damage themselves and we should welcome
that i mean to the extent that the left
is stinking it up
let's encourage the right to screw
themselves if we can and third and this
is really the key and i've told you this
before
the so-called anti-trump republicans liz
cheney adam kinzinger etc
they still mostly supported everything
trump did
they simply think joe biden won in 2020.
these are not our friends these are
still republican nuts
who accept the election results
liz cheney accepts trump did something
wrong with ukraine but still voted with
trump almost all the time and what's
happened is that the bar has been so
lowered
that it can be tricky to remember these
are still extremists right if liz cheney
is basically dick cheney politically
we saw dick cheney accurately
as a neocon kook when he was the vice
president
liz cheney more or less under the same
republican umbrella as dick cheney
now seems so much more reasonable
because she said trump lost the bar is
so low that they say one or two things
that are true and we go these are good
people these are not our friends these
are not our allies and let's not get
confused and believe that they are we're
going to have more on this and you can
send us your comments
on our instagram find us at
davidpakmanshow on instagram and if you
want to see a really wacky hate mail i
got yesterday uh follow me on instagram
david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
so this you absolutely have to see and i
want to make sure i set this up for you
so you understand the full scope of this
months ago we started seeing this
partisan gap on covet
and the coveted rates were higher in
trump counties
hospitalizations were higher deaths have
gone now almost three times higher in
the heavy
trump counties really bad places to be
uh for covid and maybe in some other
ways compared to the big biden counties
huge huge gap and i don't know if you
guys remember i but i jokingly said
how soon are they going to start saying
isn't it suspicious that you've got all
these unvaccinated trump supporters
getting coveted isn't it suspicious
that this is taking place and of course
the reason would be simple well the
vaccine protects you
the vaccine protects you to some degree
from infection and it protects you to a
greater degree from serious illness
hospitalization and death it was a joke
i joked that we would hear that but you
can't joke about it anymore
because the joke has become a reality
radical right-wing broadcaster stu
peters
has the flu or covid he's not saying it
seems he doesn't know he's probably not
even going to get tested
and he is actually saying
i have this because it was a targeted
attack
they are targeting people
with coal flu and covid as a weapon to
punish them for not getting vaccinated
apparently
let's check out the clip
you'll notice at first it's like almost
too much for his guest deanna lorraine
but then she quickly falls in line with
the insanity and even adds her own
craziness you've got to see this i
wouldn't be surprised if this so-called
cold the virus the flu that i have right
now was a targeted attack on me do you
speculate that some of that might be
going on as well
a targeted attack yeah i mean absolutely
like the bio weapon being released on
you this this sociopath tony fauci when
he chimerically engineered this
taxpayer-funded uh lab originated
intentionally released wuhan china virus
i mean that could probably be used
against people automatically i mean
people republicans conservatives talk
show host people being targeted with
this virus right i mean don't you think
so they can paint these 100 pictures
this paint the picture about oh well stu
peter's got the coronavirus he did it to
himself because he's not very vaccinated
exactly no 100 i mean we talked about
last week with the world economic forum
uh launching this bubble gun that you
can just point a gun spacially and
someone gets a vaccine i'm sure that
they have the power to you know target
somebody to get coveted all of the very
prominent republicans and people who
have been outspoken against vaccines um
pastors etc suddenly they come down with
a bad case of covenant makes the news
you know anti-vaxxer anti-massacre
pastor comes down with covet it's all
too suspicious and i absolutely think
people are being targeted well they're
going to have to try harder than this
because this thing whatever i have is
weak as hell um you're stronger than it
that's what i got i got a what a little
bit of a stuffy nose now and a little
bit of a scratchy throat whoopty do
she's literally saying it she's saying
it's suspicious these people they speak
out against vaccines
before you know it
they have coveted
it must be
that someone is infecting them on
purpose folks
that's how it works
this is the absolute epitome of the
unfalsifiable argument if you don't get
vaccinated
and you get covid
it's not because you were unvaccinated
and totally unprotected
it's because they infected you as a
punishment with a weaponized virus
because you didn't get vaccinated that
is an argument that cannot be defeated
with facts or reason because they didn't
reason their way into it now also it's
funny that i mean you know like quite
frankly who the hell is stu peters is
stupider so important that anyone would
even bother to infect him deliberately
like who cares that stu peters is
against vaccines why would you even go
and try to infect him and that's another
aspect of conspiratorial thinking that
is very self-centered it assumes a level
of self-importance that goes beyond any
common sense or reason you simply aren't
that important a player in this whole
thing and sometimes what pushes people
we've i mean at this point how much have
we talked about conspiracism and
conspiratorial thinking a ton and
there's so many aspects to this
gullibility and all these different
things
oftentimes when when you believe you are
a player in the whole thing
the delusion is that you see yourself as
so important as one of seven eight
billion people on this planet that
clearly they would be targeting you or
paying attention to what you're saying
it's really quite simple
he caught a virus
against which he wasn't vaccinated it
might be covered and he seems to not
have gotten the covet vaccine it might
be flu
i'm guessing he also doesn't get the flu
vaccine that's it he's at a higher risk
because he didn't get vaccinated and it
got him there is no big mystery here but
it always has to be more complicated
partially by putting himself at the
center of this grand conspiracy and they
are so close to getting it i mean you
know
deanna lorraine
she actually says you know all these
unvaccinated people are getting sick
well apply occam's razor
maybe it's because the vaccine really
does protect you
no she has to stop short of that and
instead go with the more complicated
explanation the unvaccinated people
people are being targeted by those who
have weaponized the virus as a
punishment for not falling in line with
vaccination and as i don't remember who
it was now
is it peter pagoda i don't remember who
came up with this
you're not gonna reason your way out
of a belief you didn't reason your way
into and we're not gonna reason people
out of beliefs that they they didn't
reason their ways into their way into
and that's exactly what is happening
with stu peters right here
uh the midterm election season for 2022
is likely to start earlier than ever
this time around i was talking to
our youtube rep recently
and he said expect interest in these
2022 midterms
to start and to see more serious
campaigning and interest on youtube as
early as spring of next year rather than
more like early summer
and there are some really good reasons
why we would expect that not only are
there increasingly interesting
particular races to look at including
the texas gubernatorial election where
beta o'rourke is running
pennsylvania senate we now have this
quack cure promoter dr mehmet oz we also
have john fetterman running on the
democratic side okay that's interesting
so we've got interesting races starting
to fill the docket but the stakes are
extremely high
in terms of who controls the house and
senate starting in january of 2023 and
we could go through a long list of
reasons that this is important including
to what degree republicans will be able
to stonewall anything joe biden tries to
do
they've been partially stonewalling
everything so far they might completely
stonewall everything if they take
control of the house
but maybe just as importantly is the
reality that the current republican
party
is wackier than it has ever been
and among their goals is this simmering
idea
of making donald trump speaker of the
house
if they take control of the house of
representatives in november now you
might be saying whoa
whoa stop the clock david trump isn't
running for house how could it be the
speaker you may or may not know one does
not have to be
a member of the house of representatives
to be speaker of the house where i'll
i'll talk to ro khanna about this when
we have them back on the show soon
the house can vote for anybody if the
house decides they want me to be speaker
of the house i could be speaker of the
house and starting months ago there was
this idea which was mentioned on steve
bannon's bizarre program
of installing donald trump as speaker of
the house even without him being a
member of the house of representatives
impeaching joe biden and then having
donald trump
preside over the vote to impeach joe
biden in the house
beleaguered radical republican
congressman matt gates is really into
this idea
starting back in july he started talking
about if we win in 22
we will make donald trump speaker of the
house and at the time it seemed that it
might have just been a publicity ploy to
fundraise get attention maybe raise
money for his legal defense fund but
matt gates mentioned it again in august
and he mentioned it again yesterday
senior white house correspondent for
yahoo news alexander nazarian published
a tweet about this saying quote matt
gates just told me at a press conference
that if republicans win the house in 22
he will move to install trump as house
speaker so there are really three
questions here
question one is matt gates serious he
appears to be
second question
would republicans actually nominate
trump to be speaker of the house if they
took control and the third question is
if nominated would republicans overall
actually vote to make donald trump
speaker of the house the answers to the
first two questions are pretty simple
matt gates is serious
and i do think that donald trump would
be nominated for speaker of the house if
republicans take control in 2022. the
third question is the key question
just because
republicans take control and someone
nominates trump to be speaker
do they really elect trump to be speaker
of the house understand that
it's an open question not morally but
strategically if trump is don't do
particularly well in the november
midterms if donald trump's power within
the party seems diminished it's less
likely that republicans would be willing
to do something so cartoonish on the
other hand and particularly if
republicans take control of the house on
the basis of many trumpists winning new
seats in the house it is completely
plausible that republicans would be
willing to make trump speaker of the
house and it would be one of the most
cartoonish and pathetic
circumstances in american politics in a
very very long time unfortunately
the combination of historical trends
where the first midterm after a new
president is usually bad for that party
meaning it would be bad for democrats in
november combined with gerrymandering
combat combined with population shifts
that might see democrats losing a few
seats just on that basis it is looking
more and more
like republicans are going to win the
house in november
it's not a guarantee
and when i say that i'm not saying it so
that we do nothing i'm saying it so that
we don't throw in the towel and we
actually fight for the house because if
we lose that house
it's going to be very very bad for a
long period of time
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show so we spoke earlier in the show
about joe biden warning russian
president vladimir putin don't invade
ukraine if you do it we're going to put
in place economic sanctions you're not
going to like it don't do it well tucker
carlson doesn't like it he doesn't like
what joe biden is saying
last night fox news propagandist tucker
carlson
sided with russia and with vladimir
putin saying the president
of russia
just wants to keep his western borders
secure now i already told you earlier
that russia has been massing troops at
the border with ukraine the idea being
they're either gauging what the reaction
would be to a potential invasion
or they're actually planning an invasion
of ukraine and joe biden went to putin
yesterday and said don't invade ukraine
we will punish you economically if you
do tucker
went on a 14-minute rant last night
defending russia's actions saying it's
biden who should be careful because next
thing you know he might start a war if
he threatens putin so there are so many
things here to talk about let's first
look at a couple of clips here is tucker
accurately saying you know
the risk to iowans
from putin and russia is very low and
tucker is absolutely right about that
we're going to freeze germany and
luxembourg and that's going to teach
vladimir putin again what you just saw
there is a child who has no idea what
she's talking about but keeps talking
anyway we will defend ukraine says joni
ernst
remember this is a senator from iowa so
what happens if we don't defend ukraine
joni ernst will kids in des moines grow
up to speak russian
no one asked her that question she's
never thought about it for a moment
that all is reading from the same
talking points from adam schiff to roger
wicker to joni ernst great okay so i
mean tucker's right he's condescending
he's pathetic he's a propagandist but
he's right the the russia thing is not a
risk to kids in iowa where joni ernst is
a senator and i wish that that had been
the perspective so many more times in
american history when we were doing
military engagements iraq comes to mind
as one example but we aren't talking
about military intervention here at
least not right now nor do i support one
what we're talking about here is
economic sanctions
and
participating in the shared defense of
ukraine so tucker continues we're going
to kind of go back
to what he said before the clip we just
watched take a look but what's so
interesting and ought to make you sit up
and pay attention is suddenly partisan
republicans are making identical noises
just this afternoon senator roger wicker
of mississippi not a genius famously but
still a sitting republican center
went on fox news to say we may need to
send american troops to ukraine and
possibly because this isn't insane or
anything
think about the use of nuclear weapons
got that in our back pocket nuclear
weapons
roger wicker sitting u.s senator
no one in washington laughed at roger
wicker
this is so crazy that no one seems aware
of how crazy it is they're all just
sitting back and listening to tori and
newland
tell them
what we need to do
how much has this penetrated the psyche
of washington dc well here's a sad piece
of tape this is joni ernst who's totally
affable nice republican sort of
reasonable in most things from the
midwest suddenly sounding like a
bloodthirsty warmonger something like
actually adam schiff when she talks
about that dastardly vladimir putin
he needs to say to vladimir putin that
we are no longer going to allow you to
to continue with the nordstream 2
pipeline we need you to know and
understand that we will defend ukraine
we will provide them assistance he needs
to make that very clear
putin is so bad we're going to cut off
natural gas to western europe
in retaliation against him in december
we're gonna freeze germany and
luxembourg and that's gonna teach
vladimir putin again what you just saw
there is a child who has no idea what
she's talking about but keeps talking
anyway okay so then we get to like the
part about joni ernst that i played for
you earlier
so
here's the deal with this
your reaction might be
republicans just love russia
so of course tucker is siding with
russia and it is true
that increasingly under trump
these republicans are
more and more sort of smitten
by these authoritarian strong men and
russia is is you know one example of
that but this is actually bigger than
that and remember i don't want war with
russia i didn't want trump going to war
with russia i don't want joe biden going
to war with russia i'm not calling for
war with russia at all period
what i want to point out to you
is that for republicans
the principle
is that democrats are always in the
wrong under obama the focus was
beta obama
let putin take crimea
and he just let him do it he walked all
over obama once again why didn't obama
go to war why didn't obama deploy troops
why did obama let putin do whatever the
hell he wanted
income uh donald trump
the focus then became
why wouldn't we want to get along with
putin getting along is good you know
their voices would go up three octaves
putin didn't do anything wrong
let's be friends trump is right not to
go after putin trump is right not to
treat putin
uh uh strongly and instead treats him
with kid gloves you warmongering
liberals stop saying trump should be
going aggressive with putin
and then now it's joe biden and now it's
well
even merely threatening economic
sanctions is crazy putin's not that bad
putin's just protecting his border well
but hold on a second guys
under obama you flipped out because
obama didn't stop putin from taking
crimea
now biden is bad for doing something at
least an economic threat i thought
wasn't this what you said obama was
wrong for not doing and now biden is
wrong for doing it and at the end of the
day
these people are truly pathetic because
there are no underlying values or
principles with foreign policy the only
underlying principle is attack democrats
the principle is
it's always the fault of some democrat
doing something wrong either democrats
did the wrong thing
by doing something or democrats did the
wrong thing by not doing something or
democrats wanted the republican to do
the wrong thing but fortunately the
republican was smart and strong and wise
enough not to do it under obama obama
was that democrat
under trump it was other democrats
saying why is trump treating putin like
this and not taking him seriously and
then under biden it goes back to being
joe biden
this is amazing even for tucker
the defense of putin here but at this
point i probably shouldn't even really
be that surprised
um we
let
suspected
let me back up
when trump got coveted
we knew what we were being lied to about
a lot of different things
earlier in the week and last week we
came to learn
that one of the things we were being
lied about with regard to trump's covid
was when he was sick and it is now
abundantly clear before it was 90 clear
now it's completely clear
trump had had a positive test
before
that infamous debate with joe biden at
which trump showed up late and his staff
said we don't know trust us
he was tested we're not going to test on
site he was tested for covid we now know
trump had coveted during that debate
we also suspected
that trump was way sicker than was being
admitted to by his doctors and his aides
his political aides at that time and we
now have more information about that
uh thanks again
to mark meadows trump's form one of
trump's former chiefs of staff who has
now uh published a ton of information
about what was going on behind the
scenes
we have learned number one that donald
trump's oxygen was not just a little low
but it was dangerously low back in
october of 2020 when he tested positive
for covid19
we also learned that uh the diagnosis in
general was far more serious
that trump's medical team actually
pulled mark meadows aside and said
listen
his oxygen levels are really really low
for his age
86 or lower is very very dangerous
there is also the
revelation now that donald trump was so
weak that he could not even carry his
own briefcase and that mark meadows was
uh advised you've got to convince trump
to get to walter reed hospital now
before things take a turn for the worse
because if you're trying to hide how
sick he is if the guy can't even walk to
the helicopter it's going to be
impossible impossible to continue hiding
it meadows went in to tell trump sir you
know we got to move you it's time to go
to walter reed
trump was supposedly sitting up in bed
in a t-shirt and looked like he was not
going to be able to go anywhere and
meadow says you know we always saw the
guy in either golf workouts or suit uh
golf outfits or suit and tie
um and trump looked very very different
here
he was a mess his hair was a mess on and
on
and uh mark meadows said to trump it's
better you walk out of here today under
your own power
than being brought out on a gurney or a
stretcher
and that was the time at which it was
determined by trump yeah i'd better go
uh and the idea was okay
um let's go out and carry your briefcase
but he's too weak even to carry the
briefcase we have now learned now are
any of these
details surprising no we had every
reason to suspect
that um trump was very very sick and
much sicker than was being admitted is
trump now admitting that this is what
went on no
no trump is denying these accounts and
saying
uh i didn't have covet during the debate
it's fake news uh all this different
stuff uh trump denies everything so it
seems pretty clear to me if you say well
what's the most likely thing here what's
the most reasonable and likely
explanation mark meadows is probably
telling the truth i don't know of any
reason particularly when you know that
if you
tell these stories being mark meadows
trump's going to lose his mind he's
going to slam you it's going to be
completely crazy um and at the same time
uh it follows what we knew at the time
dr sean conley was being very very
squishy and evasive with
is did trump need oxygen he's not on
oxygen today
no but did he in the past since coming
here
um
he has not been on oxygen today
okay when did he first test positive
i'm not going to look backwards we want
to look forward to the president
regaining his health it all fits with
everything that was going on trump
always wanting to minimize anything bad
and play up anything good
the very strange and narrow language
used by his doctors and on and on and on
so no shock no surprise uh just imagine
i mean i think the real takeaway here is
imagine how crazy things would have
gotten
had trump refused to go to the hospital
initially
and ultimately needed to be brought on a
stretcher what what would that have done
um and if trump had ended up even sicker
and stayed in the hospital
closer to the elections i mean i it all
the way it went ended up seeming not
that bad for trump at the end of the day
still ultimately did not get him
re-elected but it could have been much
much worse and we're learning that
through these revelations from mark
meadows
we have a voicemail number and that
number is
to david p
you can call anytime i got a very
interesting voicemail from the eggman
explaining a conversation he recently
had with someone take a listen to this
this is interesting
hey dave i just had a business
transaction with a conservative
republican in western new york some guy
i met i sold him something in my house
right so anyway we're making this deal
and i told him i'm a registered
republican but i hate trump and didn't
vote for him by the way that's true did
you know i am a registered republican
anyway i told the guy this and now that
he thinks i'm a republican he gave me
the inside dirt like he's talking to his
own team and i said he is so fearful
that trump is going to run in 2024 and
if trump runs they're going to lose and
they need to find somebody better than
trump because
biden is sick and harris is horrible and
they're going to get nobody in the damn
side but whoever they get is going to
beat trump so they need to replace trump
this guy was a terrified republican
conservative he thinks the world is
falling is caving in and he thinks uh
radical left wings are taking over
everything so um
they're scared dave and it was neat to
hear this guy talk to me like i was on
his own side it was really really
eye-opening and interesting yeah i mean
i think what the the thing to think
about here is
um it's
there there's no exciting person on the
democratic side right now i mean
you know let's be honest joe biden
running for reelection isn't exciting
and i don't know if he will win
uh joe biden not running and it being
kamala harris is not exciting and i
don't know that she will win there's not
really excitement and you guys know that
i just in in general i'm not super
impressed with politicians anyway uh
they're just people at the end of the
day but there's no one that's exciting
me on the democratic side on the
republican side you have the deep
devoted trump cultists who still are
completely on his side
but you also have what the eggman is
describing here
people who
believe trump's time has come and gone
and that trump will run again due to
narcissism and lose
and they don't know who to point to
either and i think this is why ron
desantis name keeps coming up he's
competent in the sense of being able to
keep it together
he is trumpian in a lot of his ideology
and maybe
more dangerously effective at being able
to get a lot of that stuff done but it
is interesting that other than desantis
the people that the names you hear
mentioned by the right like more
traditional republicans i don't think
they have a chance i think the
republican electorate has moved beyond
sort of a traditional republican at this
point in time and that's why you say
well if it's got to be trumpian
but less whacked and maybe younger
that's why the desantis possibility
keeps coming up so we're going to wait
and see on today's bonus show we will
talk about joe biden's federal
contractor vaccine mandate being blocked
by a judge
we will talk about the legalization of
suicide pods in switzerland
and we will also talk about the bill
backed by progressives in congress for a
four day work week
what is the chance that this passes all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joint.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman